what does justice look like in America
it's about literal generations of
poverty being attacked because people
cannot afford their freedom almost half
a million people are sitting in a jail
cell tonight and they haven't been found
guilty of any crime here people are
actually being held solely because they
cannot afford to pay that's the only
reason this is cash bail $500 $1,000
$5,000 in communities where families are
one check away from devastation
bail is devastation in this three-part
series from aj+ we'll look at how bail
rips families apart I'm just a regular
mom and they threw me into jail like I
was a hardened criminal how the
for-profit bail industry breeds distrust
these people are lost children they are
gonna hide they're gonna run and the
disruptors who are reimagining what
public safety should look like simply
having money does not make you a better
human being it's just purely a wealth
based detention scheme full stop there
is a war on black people and in order
for us to love each other well we have
to fight for our freedom
in America we shouldn't have to buy our
freedom but that's exactly what bill
forces us to do okay picture this you're
driving down the street you make an
illegal u-turn a cop pulls up your
record you've got a warrant for not
paying some speeding tickets to get
booked the judge uses what's called a
bail schedule to set a predetermined
amount $500 based on the alleged front
if you can post it you walk out if not
you sit in jail until trial
that's bail paying money to the court so
you can secure your release from jail
while you wait for your trial but what
if you can't afford it
take a look most of the people in jail
right now across the u.s. haven't been
found guilty of any crime in the eyes of
the law they're innocent that's almost
half a million people just waiting in
what's called pretrial detention that's
more people than some countries have in
their jails and prisons combined my name
is Monty Simmons and I am a bill reform
activists in southwest Missouri these
people are in jail because they can't
pay to get out it's kind of backwards
post you get punished and then at the
end of your jail time they figure out if
you actually did it
bail has been sold to us as like the
solution but it's not it's it's the
problem it's what's keeping our jails so
swollen this is Mary Moreno
she's an organizer in Houston Texas who
helps bail people out of jail who can't
afford it money shouldn't be the
deciding factor whether you're in jail
or not they say how can you not have
$500 but a lot of people don't have $500
right the American justice system is
actually rigged to favor the rich and
being rich can mean different things to
different people
40% of Americans can't afford to come up
with $400 in an emergency so imagine
you're this woman who had to come up
with 2000
your grandmother in Texas you're
babysitting your grandson he runs out
into the street nothing that happens but
a driver calls the cops you get booked
your bail is set at $2,000 you can't
afford that so you sit in jail for two
weeks until a community group advocates
for your release
it wasn't anything all right children
run into the street all the time this
police officer when he arrived he sees a
tunnel and he's like I'm gonna take you
to jail instead of like how can I help
you black and brown folks are policed
both more harshly and more frequently
than their white counterparts and the
system just builds from there
Blake strode represents people who are
targeted and criminalized by the legal
system once you've labeled someone is a
criminal they're sort of in a subhuman
category shows like law and order
they're popular because they feed into
this notion that we already believe
about good and bad you've never seen an
episode that focused on the ways in
which implicit bias determines who's
getting police in the first place you'll
never see an episode that talks about
rampant use of force in in a poor black
community disparities in sentencing and
charging you also never see the cost in
people's live here's what he means
you're a mom of seven kids you're
accused of stealing two beers you get
booked a judge sets bail at $15,000 you
can't pay so you spend nine months in
jail you lose your job you miss your
grandmother's funeral
and you get separated from your kids
people who cannot afford bail
experienced these catastrophic setbacks
that are just incredibly hard to come
out of that's zhiguli
they lead media efforts at a law firm in
st. Louis Missouri
the central theme I hear from people
impacted by cash bail is loss loss of
time with their children with their
brothers and sisters with their parents
you have this system that is operating
in all elements of a person's life in a
systemically racist way from the use of
force at that initial arrest the charges
the sentencing and then the conditions
that people are held in it so let's
break that down
statistically black and brown people are
more likely to be arrested more likely
to get assigned bail and less likely to
be able to afford it and the amount they
have to pay can be totally unrealistic
the median bail for a felony is $10,000
the median annual income for someone
who's arrested is $19,000
bail has absolutely nothing to do with
the thing we're taught in like grade
school which is that you're innocent
until proven guilty it's just purely a
wealth based detention scheme full stop
and people will say oh they were only
there for a few weeks or a few days
in fact spending just three days in jail
can actually start to change the legal
outcome of cases you can't help collect
evidence you can't meet with your
attorney as often as you may want to or
may need to pre-trial detention can lead
people to plead guilty to a crime they
didn't commit
meet judge Daryl Jordan of Harris County
Texas he's helping to reform the bail
system there it's a plea bargain system
instead of a criminal justice system
remember the vast majority of cases in
the u.s. never make it to trial
you see prosecutors know that people
just want to go home when you have to
make a decision do I plead this case and
go home or stay here and fight it and
risk losing everything that I have most
people are going to take the conviction
in a perfect world you'd get arrested
and tried on the same day but in reality
it can take so much longer than that
so bondsman like Jael McEntire offer you
another way out the purposes without in
the industry is to make money here's how
it works
we get a call
your son was built the judge sets bail
at $1,000 you sign the contract
guaranteeing he'll show up in court your
bounty is ten thousand dollars it could
be more it could be like we get an out
of date we refer to ourselves as the
grease that keeps the wheels of the
criminal justice system moving ken good
is an attorney for the Texas Bail Bonds
industry these people are lost children
they need somebody there to hold their
hand and explain to them this is the
process this is what we need to do to
get you back on track we will come and
get you we'll take you to the court and
yes there's a ton of babysitting
involved but that's what we do that's
what we've been doing for 200 years
so the for-profit bail industry is built
on this really shaky disproven myth that
people won't come back to court unless
they have money to lose but policy
changes have shown that people do come
back take Washington DC for example the
district got rid of cash bail in 1992
since then they've had a 90 percent
response rate for people who are let go
people want to go back to their lives
they want to be with their families and
friends their church their community
it's not like they have you know endless
amount of resources to just up and move
and start a whole new life I think that
there are people who really believe that
the whole problem is we have poor people
and they should not be held accountable
because they're poor I was raised in a
very small town we were poor and we were
always taught that if you work hard you
can overcome there's almost an
expectation in this pull yourself up by
your bootstraps society that the person
just needs to do it themselves they just
need to get their life together but what
no one is talking about is this
overarching oppressive system let's
break that cycle let's help people so
instead of like investing and
incarceration let's invest in mental
health and housing and drug addiction
recovery and get this letting people go
is actually so much cheaper than keeping
them locked up right now taxpayers in
Harris County Texas spend 87 dollars
every
day four each inmate behind bars but to
release them with services and reminders
about showing back up to court that
costs just 83 cents a day instead we
want to criminalize them lock them up
and throw away the key and so jail
populations just keep growing between
1999 and 2014 the number of people held
in jail before trial accounted for 99
percent of the total growth which begs
the question what if the bail system is
doing more harm than good or worse what
if it's just broken the bail system is
functioning just as it was always
intended to you can peel back the pages
of history
going back to slavery what happened
after Civil War and Black Codes and Jim
Crow now we are in the new Jim Crow as
America continues this struggle for
civil rights and for human rights and
movement for black lives it's almost
like with every push forward
there is a socially conservative push
backwards what are all those waves
accomplishing they are accomplishing the
engineering of black invisibility we
often think about young black men being
the ones behind bars but women are
becoming a critical group who are locked
up and forgotten I lost my apartment I
lost my job I had to rebuild everything
and I'm still rebuilding in part two of
our series we'll take a look at women
whose lives have been irreversibly
impacted by the bail system
I just want answers I want to know why
and how the system failed my mother hey
guys it's Angie thanks for watching do
you know somebody who's been impacted by
cash bail we want to hear your stories
tell us about it in the comments below
and don't forget to Like share and
subscribe to aj+